Okay, we're here on CNN
with the co-author of the book,
The Canceling
of the American Mind,
-Greg Lukianoff.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
CNN senior political analyst
and anchor, John Avlon,
and special correspondent
for PBS NewsHour,
Jane Ferguson.
Okay, here are the questions.
That the people of America
want to know of our CNN panel.
You're often
on a CNN panel, right?
Yes, I am.
Okay, so this
is just new to you,
not new to you.
What does the panel think
of choosing Taylor Swift
as Time Magazine Person
of the Year?
One hundred percent for it.
She totally deserves it.
-I'm not kidding. (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
No, I mean, yeah, who can argue?
It was her and the cat, though.
The cat should get credit.
-BILL MAHER: Well, she's--
I mean--
-(ALL CHUCKLING)
It's a phenomenal year.
I mean, we have not seen a year
like that in show business,
maybe ever.
What are the panel's thoughts
on Hunter Biden being indicted?
-Hey, look...
-(ALL LAUGH)
BILL: Why ask? (LAUGHS)
It just shows
that the equal justice
under law exists.
The president's son, you know,
is gonna get busted
for evading taxes and you know,
he did it in a lot of...
A moment of grief
and that doesn't really matter
because you gotta obey the law
no matter whose son you are.
-No matter who...
-BILL: It does really...
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
JOHN AVLON: We've got
a two-tier justice system.
It does really point out
that one side does consider
the law a little more
seriously than the other.
And the fact that they kind of
compare it to Trump,
like Hunter Biden
is not our hero.
(GREG LUKIANOFF LAUGHS)
-Okay?
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Okay, what kind of interference
can we expect from Russia
-as the 2024 election heats up?
-JANE FERGUSON: None needed.
-Well, but...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
JOHN: No, but...
-Unfortunately.
-Sadly, it's true.
But actually there's a story
that just came out yesterday
in the UK but the US
was involved as well,
that Russia
is doing cyber hacking
specifically with the goal
of not only disrupting
their election,
but eroding faith
in democracy itself.
And I think
that's the larger stakes.
And we've seen this on TikTok,
a lot of these things
that go viral.
You've discussed that.
You know, and now,
you see, Xi--
You know, Trump losing
no opportunity to praise Xi
in every campaign speech.
You know, the guy,
Donald Trump loves dictators,
but I think
that dramatically increases
the chance of interference
only because people
are gonna want...
Those autocratic alternatives
are gonna want to degrade
democracy and put us
on a path towards decline.
But are we flattering ourselves
in thinking that
that's what they need to do
as opposed to sit back
-and watch? I mean, like...
-No.
There was, of course,
the misinformation campaign
-and bots on Twitter.
-JOHN: Yeah.
Making us all get outraged
and row and fight.
But it feels like
that's taken on an organic life
of its own now.
And perhaps we're flattering
ourselves by saying,
"It must be an interference."
We see this in other parts
of the world
you know, whenever people
rise up against, you know,
their leaders and everyone says
it's a conspiracy.
By all means, Russia will
and would love to interfere.
-They are.
-I kind of wonder if,
like, these days,
they really need to.
I mean, this election
is not looking too tight.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. In canceling,
we talk a lot
about what experts have done
to undermine
their own credibility,
unfortunately, in recent years.
And that's also a big thing
that Russia's trying
to do as well.
And unfortunately,
they're like, you know,
they're complimenting each other
in the worst possible way.
Okay, what did the panel think
of Vivek Ramaswamy's
performance at the debate
this week?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
I had to watch that?
-Yeah. I did.
-BILL: Did you watch? Oh.
(LAUGHS)
-It's not on the test, Greg.
-(ALL LAUGH)
If you didn't see it, it was--
In one answer,
he managed to connect
every conspiracy theory
from the 21st century.
-GREG: Well, that's cool.
-From 9/11.
Well, except,
it was clearly a dog whistle
to folks on the far right
to sort of connect 9/11,
say January 6th
was an inside job,
to talk about
the great replacement theory
and saying there was
a Democratic Party platform.
And to say-- and to repeat
2020 election lies,
which are now a litmus test
within the party.
That symbolizes everything wrong
in our politics.
It's totally disgusting.
It's disqualifying.
It's pathetic
and it's pandering. He's done.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-I should've gone with him.
-It pisses me off.
I think it also, though,
really speaks
to a level of desperation.
I mean, you have to be
pretty scared
to start connecting
more and more,
and more
conspiracy theories together.
I mean, there's got to be like
a limit to where, you know,
once you've had too many
then you really look
like you're losing.
GREG: Gotta work in pizzagate.
-Right.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Well, he did
with the Chris Christie joke.
-Oh, did he really?
-Well, he worked in pizza.
-(ALL LAUGH)
-There's something.
Didn't he say something?
I mean, he made,
he made a fat joke
at Chris Christie.
I just want to--
I tried to like this guy.
I had him on my podcast.
Had him on the show.
-He's a personable guy.
-GREG: Mm-hmm.
But I just got to say,
youth shows itself.
I mean, he kept saying--
The debates I watched,
he kept saying,
it's time for a new generation,
which they all say
when the young guy comes along.
And this just showed, it's not.
-Because this generation...
-Not that guy.
What? Well, not that guy.
Because it just showed,
you know, come back--
My advice to them, stop.
Just stop it. Go away.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-Come back. He's 38 years old.
Come back in ten
or 20 years and say,
"Oh yeah, you know what?
I can't believe I did
what I did when I was 38."
-'Cause we can all relate
to that.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
And like, I just--
Run for office,
not just straight for president
'cause you want to get famous.
'Cause, you know,
your idiocy is showing.
I mean, it also just seems
so performative. I get it.
What he's thinking is,
the Republican party
likes dicks. It does.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But you know,
with Trump it's authentic.
-(JOHN LAUGHING)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Now, you're kind of
complimenting him.
-He's not really a dick, but...
-BILL: He's not.
-...he's trying to be one.
-I think he's playing one.
-JOHN: That's almost worse.
-That's al-- Exactly.
It is worse. It's almost worse.
Trump can't help being a dick.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
This guy is playing one.
Also, I must tell you.
A number of Indian-Americans
I know who are friends of mine
have said, "Bill,
please tell America,
he does not represent us."
You know, that's like,
that's a bad guy
to go out first.
-But there's Nikki Haley.
-JOHN: You got Nikki Haley.
Who, you know, like,
do I agree with everything? No.
But could I easily live under
Nikki Haley's America? Yes.
And I might even enjoy it.
I don't know.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
This is all--
What's going to happen
in the next two months
between Iowa and New Hampshire
is going to be enormously--
I mean, this is a time
for choosing.
Republicans have one last chance
to not renominate someone
who tried to overturn
our democracy.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING, CHEERING)
Okay, Jane...
Are there--
Dublin is your hometown?
-Well, New York City.
-(JOHN LAUGHS)
I come from Northern Ireland,
just north of the border.
-BILL: Oh, Northern Ireland.
-JANE: It's complex.
Yes. Oh, I know.
Are the riots in Dublin a sign
that extremist politics
are gaining a foothold
in Ireland?
Okay, so explain what--
I read it,
-but you have to explain it.
-JANE: It's pretty wild.
So, Ireland, I mean,
I had to reread
the story several times.
BILL: It was about Musk,
wasn't it?
No, It was really kind of,
it's a fomenting of a sort of
very, very tiny minority
that's very loud
and very violent.
That it basically, it's,
you know, anti-immigration
and it's all the usual populist
kind of conversation.
-I think the fact--
-But what stirred them up?
Wasn't it something on Twitter?
I refuse to call it X.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
A lot of it comes down
to like rumors
and misinformation and it--
but it's grounded.
And so, Twitter's a big,
big part of that there
in this case. But--
BILL: But Twitter's better,
isn't it?
I feel like it's so much easier
to go, "Twitter."
I refuse to call it X.
Than go, "X formally Twitter."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
X used to be a drug. You know?
That's what people used to,
you know--
I'm also going
to call Kanye, Kanye.
I'm not going to go with Ye.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-The people....
The Irish thing though.
I mean, honestly,
like, the thing that concerns me
is that whenever you start
having a pretty sort of violent,
extremely right wing
riot in Ireland,
I mean, this is just,
this is unprecedented.
BILL: We've had them here.
JANE: But yeah,
I mean, never in Ireland.
Like, I mean Ireland is,
so antithetical to everything.
You know, we know about--
Ireland was the first country
to-- by popular vote,
legalize gay marriage, you know.
I mean, Ireland is one
of the most liberal places.
Well, kind of late
in the game though.
-A lot has changed.
A lot has changed.
-What year was that?
That was fifteen years ago,
ten years ago.
That's kind of late in the game.
All right, raise a glass
to Shane MacGowan, by the way,
-speaking of Ireland.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
-BILL: Wait, what?
-GREG: But I will say...
Lead singer of the Pogues died.
The attempt to ban hate speech
in Ireland,
that got passed recently.
I see the same thing
going on in France.
And they can't seem
to understand that they passed
these anti-Semitism laws
in the '90s and somehow
anti-Semitism got worse.
And it's because you told
all the anti-Semites
that they can only talk
to other anti-Semites.
What did you expect to happen?
And this is actually
the same thing
on college campuses.
When students are not talking
to one another.
They're not like having
civil discourse.
Opinions don't go away
-'cause you ban someone
saying them.
-GREG: Exactly.
We need to get, like,
especially students on campus,
make them sit down and talk.
Make them debate.
And make them say this
to each other's faces.
This is one
of the most important things
that your show's
doing right now.
Which is defining
liberal values.
And saying, "We need to stand up
against liberalism on the left
as well as the right."
And there's a group
of common sense Democrats,
liberal patriots,
radical centrists,
that need to start taking
the conversation back.
Well said. Thank you, everybody.
-We'll see you next week
for our season finale.
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)